every weekend here on c-span - this book
a g-man's journal is about oliver
Ravel's 30 year career in the FBI he
directed or participated in major
investigations such as the JFK
assassination the Watergate break-in and
the Iran hostage crisis last month he
spoke about the book and his experiences
while at a Barnes & Noble bookstore in
Washington DC he's introduced by
bookstore spokeswoman Jane Graff
tonight we're very pleased to welcome
all of you my name is Jane Graf welcome
to Barnes & Noble Georgetown and welcome
to all of our c-span viewers across the
country from 1964 to 1994 buck Ravel
directed or participated directly in
virtually every major FBI investigation
from the JFK assassination Watergate the
Iran hostage crisis and the Gulf War
anti-terrorist operations is the former
associate deputy director in charge of
investigations the bureau's number two
career post he sealed his reputation as
a legendary maverick in federal law
enforcement now in a landmark
autobiography Revell candidly reveals
the brilliance and deep rooted flaws
behind 30 years of an FBI investigations
known early on for his street-smart
proactive and hard-hitting style inside
J edgar Hoover's Bureau Revell hunted
down mafia hitmen Ku Klux Klan type
terrorist group in Eastern black spies
quickly rising in a system that was
often its own worst enemy he discloses
why after Hoover's death in 1972 he and
other reform-minded agents moved to
modernize the FBI both tactically and
technologically and how he developed
investigative strategies innovated
specific surveillance methods and
innovated and championed special FBI
units such as special events management
and hostage rescue as skilled as advice
let's try that again
it's skilled as advising heads of state
as colouring criminals Revell was
summoned to the White House Situation
Room is the senior FBI representative to
the National Security Council he emerged
as one of our nation's leading
authorities on terrorism and national
security issues he recounts how he
proceeded persuaded Congress to enact
federal laws regarding fugitive
apprehension how he directed all
international operations including
tracking the kidnappers and killers of
hostages in Beirut International mafia
weapons smuggling and French and
Japanese industrial espionage he also
demonstrates why it is vital for the FBI
to become a global nerve center for the
world's law enforcement agencies on the
home front buck Ravel continues to
advise the National Security Council the
Pentagon
and Justice Department's on matters of
organized crime drug enforcement
white-collar crime and terrorism in his
new memoirs a g-man's journal he
proposes drastic reforms for improving
the current system and law enforcement
and justice and bluntly analyzes what
went wrong at incidents like Branch
Davidian tragedy and Wako World Trade
Center bombing in the Oklahoma City
bombing a riveting chronicle of an
extraordinary career amid history
shaping events a g-man's journal lays
bare the varied criminal threads facing
America today and sets the
crime-fighting agenda for the future
ladies and gentlemen please give me a
warm barnes ennoble welcome for oliver
buck rebel it's hard hearing all those
things that the publisher has written
and then try and come up and justify
them particularly with my colleagues
that I've worked with sitting here over
the years this book was of course a
joint effort not only my wife and many
of my former colleagues but with a young
author that helped me take government
ease and change it into a form of
written language that the public would
better understand I had never written a
first-person report or novel or anything
of this nature so writing in the first
person in an interesting fashion was one
of my first challenges and the Dwight
Williams my co-author was very very
helpful in that regard and of course my
wife Sharon made sure that I made
everything correct and accurate and
helped my memory which over the years is
not as keen as it as it once was I
actually wrote this book for several
reasons one it was not my idea I was
approached by a book producer and
convinced to do the project secondly it
was to try and bring balance to the
historical record of many of the event
events that I was fortunate enough to be
able to participate in from as the title
says the Kennedy assassination all the
way to the Oklahoma City bombing such
things as Watergate the iran-contra
affair the Pan Am 103 investigation
worlds
then largest terrorist investigation the
entire effort against the Klan and the
elements that were espousing hate
throughout the south and other parts of
our nation during the the Civil Rights
Act even in those elements of that
movement who moved into criminal
violations and attempted to essentially
bring our government to a halt and and
in fact engaged in many instances and
murder and bombings to carry out their
philosophical goals those things happen
at a time in our society when our
country was not sure where it was going
or how it wanted to get there and one
agency in reality was in the midst of
all of this turmoil and it was the FBI
starting with its legendary and longtime
director J Edgar Hoover who of course
died in 1972 and then trying to come
through the transition with Watergate
occurring right after he died
on into the the current events that
you're all familiar with that is
occurring on our on our national scene
just today an individual was indicted
for the Atlanta Olympic Park bombing a
case that is of course been going on now
for two and a half years the Unabomber
was finally identified and apprehended
at an espionage agent a former NSA
analyst was indicted yesterday so the
events and activities that the FBI is
deeply involved in are very important to
our society and it was my intention to
try and bring some balance to what has
become the the norm which is to bash
federal agents and agencies to make them
responsible for many of the ills of our
society and to blame them for a great
deal of the difficulty that we face
whether or not there's any substance to
that at all now in this book I do not
excuse the mistakes that have been made
and there have been many an agency with
25,000 people will make mistakes it has
and will make some in the future but I
try and point out the exceptional
dedication and work that the special
agents and other employees of the FBI
bring to their country
the contributions they make and indeed
the very significant level of safety and
security that they bring to our society
I've had an opportunity to travel all
around the world and I can tell you no
other country has an organization like
the FBI nowhere else can a organization
investigate at the head of state no
where else can they investigate sitting
judges are members of the legislature as
has the FBI and done so without any
political agenda in spite of the Oliver
Stone scenarios that you see coming out
of Hollywood today today's FBI the
twenty seven or eight thousand people in
it are just as dedicated as those that I
joined in nineteen sixty four when I
entered the agency so in large part
although this story is based around
around my career it is really the story
of the FBI as it went through a
transition from the years of j edgar
Hoover who built the organization and
who in his latter years brought it into
controversy to the current FBI which is
expanding its responsibilities on a
global basis and is a very important
force to see that terrorism
international organized crime which is
spreading and proliferating drug
trafficking and other internationally
linked criminal organizations are
thwarted in their efforts to essentially
take what was the dichotomy of the Cold
War and what President Bush called the
new order and turned it into a world
disorder and world Anarchy because in
the 21st century the first line of
defense in my mind is going to be
federal law enforcement to protect us
from the international drug traffickers
from the interlinked organized crime
groups from the terrorist organizations
which now have grown up not only with
state sponsors but also now with very
strong philosophical basis to where they
want to maximize the casualties and
punish America for being the opposition
the the so-called Great Satan these are
the events that will challenge us in the
future and with weapons of mass
destruction looming not on the horizon
but actually available now
the two groups organizations and
individuals it is imperative that we
have a line of defense that is effective
and yet recognizes that what makes us
different is the rule of law and the
constitutional application of that law
is the first order of business for the
FBI I was pleased to be able to serve
the FBI and my country for 30 years
before that for five years as a Marine
officer so I wanted to be able to impart
some of that experience the involvement
of my family and how much they have
given and committed over the years and
the successes that we've had and some of
the failures that we've suffered and the
reasons for and not an explanation but
an attempt to balance the scales so that
people will understand that human beings
do make mistakes but on the whole and
given the circumstances they face the
FBI is a very very remarkable
organization I think that I look back on
this on my career and people say well
what was your most important case what
was the the case that brought you the
greatest satisfaction and I can't really
identify that case because so many did
bring that level of satisfaction whether
it was returning a child to its parents
which I had an opportunity to do on some
occasions whether it was of apprehending
a mafia hitman who had killed dozens of
people whether it was tracking down
spies who jeopardized our national
security or whether it was bringing in
drug traffickers my last arrest in
Dallas Texas before I retired was of a
Mexican drug trafficker whose
organization had killed more than a
dozen people his bodyguard was
personally responsible for killing 18
people and he was preying upon the young
people in Dallas bringing drugs in from
Mexico and getting them hooked so that
they could continue to develop their
drug trafficking organization those kind
of accomplishments are not individual
they're of the organization and the
people that support it like the US
Attorney's but they still give you a
great deal of satisfaction because you
know that if you're not there
then a difference would not have been
made and they do the agents and
employees of the FBI do indeed make a
difference I think that on balance I'll
be very satisfied if this book at least
starts a dialogue among some as to the
importance of federal law enforcement
the need to redirect and restructure and
reorganize federal law enforcement to
deal with the threats of the 21st
century and it recognizes the deep
professional commitment of the career
employees of the FBI and the other
federal agencies and gives them the
appropriate tools to carry out their
duties and functions that of course is
the hope and goal of this book so with
that I'd like to at this time respond to
questions and hopefully things I haven't
covered I'll be able to answer for you
thank you area of focus is right now as
far as law enforcement and should that
be changed
well the principle for the FBI cannot
have a principal focus because it has so
many responsibilities across the entire
spectrum of a federal law enforcement
but then can have areas of emphasis and
we saw that today with the indictment of
rudolph for the Atlanta Olympic bombing
certainly terrorism is a an area of
significant responsibility the
investigations ongoing in East Africa
with the Osama bin Laden organization is
an area of principle FBI responsibility
so both domestic and foreign or
international terrorism have to be areas
of very specific interest and effort on
the part of the FBI
of course the FBI is the principal
counterintelligence agency of the United
States
so this because the Cold War is over
does not mean that we do not have
enemies both state and individual who
would take advantage of our technology
take advantage of our national security
information and turn it against our best
interest so espionage and
counterintelligence will continue to be
a very important responsibility I
believe the FBI and the DEA must do a
better job in strategizing on a global
basis the entire drug effort drug the
effort the FBI knew when we entered Drug
Enforcement in 1982 we could not solve
the drug problem what we knew was that
we had to be a holding action until our
society could come to grips with this
terrible plague that's been laid upon us
education and treatment have to be part
of the process but we also must have
federal agencies at work or in a
coordinated fashion to ensure that we
can prevent the drugs from entering the
United States and deal with the major
organizations who are trafficking drugs
to our children and essentially
destroying our next generation that must
be an effort and of course the bottom
line responsibility has to always be to
deal with corruption particularly
corruption in government the FBI has a
very unique and important responsibility
to deal with corruption at every level
of government whether it be a local
judge a county commissioner are a
federal a United States Senator are a
federal judge all of the
things have happened in the past and I'm
certain they'll happen in the future but
you must have an agency totally free
from partisan involvement or political
activity in order to do that I think
those are the continuing challenges at
the FBI faces yes sir
Klansmen Tommy Terence later turned
against the plan has said that without
the FBI there might have been up to 10
times as much violence during the civil
rights period against civil rights
workers with to you know whatever pluses
and minus of what was done what do you
think you know you learned from the
experience of fighting the Klan well the
question is about the FBI and its
involvement with the investigation of
the Klan and in the 60s and 70s what do
I think about it and could it have been
done better and did the FBI make a
difference well the answer is absolutely
it did make a difference
many many agents were sent into the
south and those that were already there
and worked tirelessly on not only
specific cases but developing
intelligence which was then shared
through agencies they could trust to
carry out preventive operations there
would have been many many many more
civil rights workers killed there would
have been much more intimidation than
did occur which was of course entirely
too much that has been largely an untold
story and and you know the dichotomy
between J Edgar Hoover and Martin Luther
King has sort of become well the FBI
wasn't really committed to the civil
rights movement and its protection under
the law that's not true at all there was
a dichotomy between dr. King and and J
Edgar Hoover but that did not affect the
FBI's commitment and if you look back
some of the cases it investigated are
still being brought to trial with
evidence they developed literally you
know three decades later I hate to think
where the South would have been and I'm
from the south I hate to think where it
would have been if it had not been for
the dedicated agents of the FBI and the
Justice Department Civil Rights Division
which put themselves on the line to
protect as best they could under very
limited federal jurisdiction at the time
the the civil rights workers and his
civil rights organizations that were
doing such important work in the south
at that time
yes sir question is how do I explain the
900 files at the at the White House I
cannot I that particular part of the
FBI's responsibility never came under my
authority that was in the what was used
to be called records management but we
had a very very rigorous standard about
sending summary reports to the White
House they had to be requested by the
White House Counsel it had to be on an
individual we knew was under
investigation for clearance for a White
House job or a high-level appointment
and they were very closely tracked and
carefully monitored it of course is
absolutely unacceptable for FBI files or
reports to be used for any sort of
partisan political purposes or to gain
advantage over one's political
adversaries and that's one thing of
significant interest I'll be watching in
ken starr's reports as to what the
bottom line is on on that particular
situation yes sir
do you think the probabilities will seem
attacked by the 21st century and the
question is weapons of mass destruction
what is the probability of attack and
what kind of target well I have to say
that I believe that the conventional
weapons of terrorists will continue to
be the most prevalent bombs have been
very effective for terrorists and they
are very easy to make and very easy to
deploy but if you really want to make a
statement if you want to traumatize the
society look at what the Amish in Riccio
did with sarin gas in Tokyo that cats
out of the bag there are now available
on the international market gas and
biological materials as well as some
radiological materials that can be
utilized and in fact someday will be
utilized and probably not in a too
distant future and they'll pick a target
that is not defended they'll pick an
easy target because they are not
concerned with mid
three advantage they're concerned with
traumatizing a society punishing a
society so they will choose something
like the World Trade Center you know no
value from a standpoint of strategic but
at fifty thousand people in a very
confined area with worldwide attention
that must be dealt with the President's
Commission on infrastructure protection
has started that process the FBI has the
lead role domestically is putting
resources into that area but it the
consequences of a terrorist attack with
a weapon of mass destruction where it be
chemical biological or radiological is
just too horrific to consider and we
must be prepared and the preparation
must be for for prevention rather than
reaction to in the past we really could
afford to react we might lose 150 people
which is a terrible tragedy but what if
the World Trade Center had been 50,000
people and what if they had contaminated
the area with a biological or chemical
or as they hope to do a radiological
material this society would still be
reeling we look at the consequences of
the Oklahoma City bombing and how it
traumatized our society for so long and
rightfully so well can you imagine if
that had been fifty thousand a hundred
thousand two hundred and fifty thousand
people then I'm afraid we'd have
draconian laws and we'd have whole
groups of people being incarcerated
detention wise as we had during World
War two that we cannot afford as a as a
society of law yes ma'am
what triggers the FBI to get involved in
this
well a domestic group it's what's called
a criminal predicate on a domestic
organization our group the FBI must have
credible information that a crime has
been or is being committed or is in the
planning conspiracy stage in order to
initiate an investigation that's carried
out under the Attorney General's
domestic guidelines in addition the
privacy law prevents the FBI from
collecting information even public
information about any organization group
or individual that is not under
investigation so where anybody in this
room can collect information about
militias and white hate groups and any
other type of organization that is
openly openly espousing violence the FBI
cannot it must have a criminal predicate
in order to collect even public
information and that of course puts it
at a great disadvantage I point out in
the book that at the time of the
Oklahoma City bombing the FBI had one
case on one militia organization in
Michigan and in spite of mr. Panetta
Leon Panetta the president's chief of
staff telling everybody on Sunday
morning television that the FBI knew all
about these groups and it was well in
hand I came on right behind him and said
I'm sorry that's not so the FBI does not
know about these groups I as a then
private citizen who much more about the
militias than the active FBI knew at the
time of the Oklahoma City bombing now of
course some of that has changed as a
result of the bombing and two spin-off
investigations from that as was true of
the World Trade Center bombing as well
but the FBI does not have legal
authority to simply initiate an
investigation without a basis to believe
that a criminal act has been or is being
committed yes sir two questions for you
the first one is how did you get your
nickname buck and the second one is
could you explain the relationship
between the FBI CIA NSA and dia that's
okay but the first one I can handle I'm
not sure I can handle the second my
nickname actually came from my
grandfather buck rains who was a native
of the Indian Territory of Oklahoma part
Cherokee and when I was a youngster
growing up I needed a nickname and I
couldn't think of a better one to adopt
in my granddad's and when your real name
is Oliver Bergen revelled a third you've
got to have a nickname and the second
part the difference is between the CIA
the DIA the FBI and what was the other
one and I say all right well the DIA and
NSA are part of the Department of
Defense the NSA is for signals
intelligence and that is its only
responsibility it collects signals
intelligence for the national security
of the United States it shares that with
the FBI and CIA on a specific as-needed
basis and with the CIA on a continuing
basis but it is a military organization
for signals intelligence the DIA is an
umbrella organization for the collection
of intelligence for specific military
purposes both its analysis and its
collection are geared towards the
military needs of the United States
whereas the CIA is an umbrella
organization for all other intelligence
activities including bringing in the
military intelligence components the
CIA's relationship with the FBI in spite
of what we read is a very positive one I
think certainly the bombings in East
Africa obviously the intelligence that
came from that was not FBI intelligence
that was CIA based and dia based
intelligence and it was integrated quite
quickly into the FBI's investigation the
FBI on the other hand is a an agency of
the Justice Department and is the
principal investigative and
counterintelligence agency of the United
States government it does not work for
the CIA or under the umbrella of the CIA
but it works together with the CIA and
as part of the intelligence community
the CIA director wears two hats he's the
director of the CIA and the director of
the US intelligence community there he
has a coordination and budget
authorization role and the FBI of
it's counterintelligence and
counterterrorism budgets pass through
that process so there is a very closely
related coordination between these
organizations but their functions and
their activities are very different yes
sir
facing the FBI going into the next
century both internally and experts I
think one of the largest challenges in
this sounds parochial I don't mean it to
be because we now have a hundred and
forty four separate federal agencies
going out in different directions
without any coordination without any any
direction or control and no one's in
charge no one's in charge as we go into
the 21st century
and we're faced with the globalization
of very very specific criminal activity
including state-sponsored crime not just
state-sponsored terrorism but there are
now nations which are kleptocracy
the government's themselves are the
criminal enterprises as we face that in
the 21st century we can't afford to have
144 separate and and competing federal
agencies we cannot have 144 agencies
enforcing over 4400 federal laws today
there's a great debate going on about
passing in federal hate crimes law well
I'm not against hate crimes but the most
specific crime to deal with a hate crime
is the capital crime of the state the
state of Wyoming has already said
they're going to indict these young men
for capital murder well the federal
government doesn't need to come in
behind that but it's just another
encroachment on the federal government
if it does of state's primary
responsibility to enforce the laws that
apply to the citizens of that state the
federal government the national
government should deal with the national
issues international issues and the
protection of our borders and that's
where we should be really concentrated
so I think the challenge to the FBI
is to try to move forward and a
consolidation effort with other federal
agencies to bring them in I think there
should be a department of federal law
enforcement rather than these hundred
and forty four separate agencies and
these groups these agencies should be
brought together in groupings and then
ultimately brought together on
functional responsibilities we can't
afford as we go forward into a new
millennia to
have the disparate and confused
enforcement picture we have in the
United States the FBI cannot lead this
but it can be an active participant and
I think a catalyst for this operation
yes sir
something came to mind when you asked me
earlier question recently a man named
Berlin Sewell died for more than 25
years mr. Sulu ran a little-known
organization inside the anti-defamation
league of B'nai bread and I'm wondering
whether you ever interacted with him or
his organization's recalls when I was
testifying on a group of we called that
was called sis peas and the FBI was
receiving a great deal of of criticism
and I was in a debate with Senator
Specter about the issue of well senator
if we have to wait until a crimes been
committed then we're going to have an
awful lot of blood on the street and
Senator specters response well in a free
society that may be the price we pay
well can we pay that price if the
casualties are going to be 250 to 500
thousand people and I think clearly we
must find a balance and we have worked
in the bureau with Binet breath with the
Southern Poverty Law Center and those
who could collect information that the
FBI was prohibited from collecting if it
had not been for Binet breath and their
investigation of white hate groups Klan
groups and so forth the FBI and the ATF
would have been much further behind than
they were when it became time to
investigate on specific criminal basis I
think I met with him at a conference one
time but I didn't have a personal
relationship some understanding about
the limitations of
Bureau had in terms of the collection of
intelligence related information
domestically yes they were accused that
sometimes of being a surrogate for the
FBI which they were never a surrogate
they would come to us and still do to my
the best of my knowledge whenever they
had specific information about groups or
individuals committing specific crimes
and that's very important for all
citizens and various groups to be able
to do and to feel comfortable in doing
from time to time to help them here we
get up to speed in areas where otherwise
who had to start fresh absolutely that's
true and their reports were credible and
they were not the only source that the
the bureau took information from but
they were credible sources of
information in an area that the bureau
could not operate you know based on the
current guidelines sir yes sir how do
you how does the FBI in a relate with
state police agencies that saying dear
sir if there's a case where the State
Police are already involved how how does
the FBI get involved or when do they
the question is how does the FBI relate
to state agencies I presume you mean
state and local agencies when they're
already involved in a case and what
would trigger FBI involvement they would
come about through one of two ways one
we would get requests for assistance
from the state or local agency which
happens all the time
or it would be a concurrent crime in
which the federal violation had also
been committed and then the the FBI
would be working the case in in
conjunction with the state or local
agencies there's not an FBI office today
that doesn't have multiple task force's
with state and local agencies on
virtually everything violent crime
terrorism fugitives Drug Task Forces and
so forth
we have 17,000 police agencies in the
United States and 144 federal agencies
task forces are the only way we can do
it it's simply the way that the job must
be done now certainly that's not the
most effective way to do it but it is
the most effective way that we can do it
under the current structure and
arrangement and so task forces and
cooperation with state and local
agencies is a very important part of the
responsibility of the FBI well I think
that just about answers all the
questions does it not thank you very
much
[Applause]
stop for you pretty much today
probably had to catch an early train
yeah and he's going all the time
well next time you come on let's go to
one to whatever part yeah I still got to
get you good video those Secret Service
gamers yeah good to see you my friend
can see you bye alright I'll look
forward already okay one for me and I
want to but I can't do one verse 10 for
it back so long ago chariot watch
thanks a lot by the way those are those
comments were terrific
yeah right on the money they said let's
get a copy of that recording I mean
those were really great Conrad this this
goes to Mac you may see my son he's a
former Marine and
see they end up with a real case of
writer's craft and then one for Jennifer
Jane fer my daughter
3je nn i fve are
thing about joy in the garage good and
this is for Sid he's one of our
contributors again a California car you
know Colorado
sit down Oliver Ravel currently runs a
security consulting business in Dallas
his book a g-man's journal is published
by Pocket Books a division of Simon &
Schuster you can learn more about it
from their website at
www.nsiindustries.com